what you call a victory and sharing our
victories you me my brother
they said I ain't doing nothing but me
because of problems to me for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings it's a bittersweet day
bitter because it's the end of season
one sweet because I couldn't have asked
for a better guest DJ Khaled in the
building the album had changed a lot
over twenty third and I think it's gonna
be a smash you know why you think you're
right okay you know what I think this
suddenly so I was listening to the you
mind video I was working right it's one
of these videos where it's huts and then
there's a snippet at the end and I just
see future spazzing on the front of the
yacht and I've never heard a song like
that all my life and I'm telling you
right now that is gonna be a [ __ ] man
yeah yeah if I could suggest the next no
no I wanted to do I wanted to um you
know like you know besides you know
promoters single at the NS surprise
something totally different and that
song is called
play about my paper yeah I'm gonna play
about it and as that it's just that
energy so I wanted I to take it from the
water to the mud before we go in the
show you do know you told me I was doing
the show so I threw in my chef to drop
off some wings from finger-licking for
the show
you know Sandow you deal with other
wings on exact you know it's a big show
but it's the finger lickin special
exactly we wouldn't undercut you with
anything Bridget Bridget Thank You
Bridget Bridget finger licking chef
thank you my regards Carol city usually
I explain the show but it's not rocket
science and everybody already knows ten
questions ten wings they get crazy hot
you make it to the end you get a plug
which is valuable when you have an album
coming off the next week biggest in the
game biggest in the game for you ready
let's do it
you called this album an uppercut and a
knockout and I always wonder when you
say these things who are you fighting
when you call this a victory who did you
defeat the fuckboys much wasn't either
way now you can answer the question you
can eat the ring it's not the Olympics
yeah but um yeah the [ __ ] boys the guys
that try to give us road blocks it
Bridget amazing um poor [ __ ] boys so
what make somebody a [ __ ] boy I mean
it's just a better word for hater mad
people bums
losers garbage like a piece of [ __ ] you
know that this is the first one this is
the weakest wing bro no I'm the team you
know we'll all right well I'm just
telling you you got some trouble on the
horizon I'm loosing my boat
that's part of the game is called life
trial to tribulation easy to win
no no no we're gonna go through some
bumps there's gonna be some peaks of
valleys there's gonna be an emotional
roller coaster kalloch I'm watching my
boat alright you ready for number two
first we feast we know about finger
lickin we went down there we know that
the red velvet cake is a problem we're
very aware it's amazing we went down
there we did the vid with you we know
all about it very very very good the
food is so good it's very good
here's the thing though you just have
good food running a restaurants not easy
even when you have good food and a lot
of rappers have gotten into the
restaurant game and there are some
success stories and there's two not so
successful stories what's your
competitive edge what makes dj khaled
special all we could never compare
myself to anyone very rare my one of
I'm a different type of person right I'm
today's today's inspiration of the new
mogul young Sam
who the hell put these sauces Sean
burger was hot you know when I got in
his game I remember somebody told me I
was just gonna be local and it's
beautiful to be able to be a local
winner but I looked at I'm like what's
mean you put restrictions on my success
Celie not DJ Khaled quite himself right
now I mean look at you now man are you
doing so blessed so this one's a Yucatec
o Caribbean habanero it's kind of got
like a fruity flavor like if you thought
these two are like kind of hot which
they're not I don't know where no Texas
Pete hot sauce is like I don't really
like too much hot there he's like on the
theory really you say you've changed a
lot
I see you out in the gym if you just
busted it and left it all on the track
what's the fastest you could run a mile
right now speed speed like if yeah would
you be good to be under eight minutes
feel bro you just different in mind if
you want to switch we could switch but
what a switch all right all right what's
worst with somebody somebody right no
prop you go listen let me tell you some
right now for all my fans I promise you
my stop doesn't mean I gave up it does
mmm-hmm by definition let me teach you
something today okay
we can't play ourselves we can't play
our health we can't hurt ourselves
that's the key now there's people that
would do dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] around hurt
themselves trying to get you that what
you call a victory you're [ __ ] on
vintners you mean my brother
they say they ain't doing number me
because of problems to me ain't gonna
say stop yeah but right now it's getting
close just take a bite just take a bite
don't don't feel like you got to clean
the wing my brother you got it you got
this man I'm not even on everything like
he's supposed to be funny hey for real
I'm glad you said that people think
that's just funny you know it's ain't no
phony [ __ ] we got sausage that last one
oh I mean listen count if it comes down
to it all your wings I'd enjoy the
conversation my brother I enjoy it I'm a
cat not talking it I answer your
question but look after your wings all
right I can't
nah I'm gonna [ __ ] up with the whole
day house what you talk anybody out in
this can you just tell the people though
station it's very important we teach the
youth because this right here dangerous
tell them but tell people think that
this is like some joke notice things
aren't hot let's hold up the camera
right there people all up in my [ __ ]
Twitter oh I miss you what why don't you
know none about this show no disrespect
to your show okay you're saying the same
the love I'm one of our boys right here
all right I'll get wings all your wings
yeah I'll do the question this [ __ ] -
hey bro if you ran
that's when we could I ain't give up
because you
good kinda did no let me tell you
something I don't encourage nobody to
jump off a building and hurt themselves
that's how we don't do it's like it's
like telling somebody I'm not saying you
saying this but it's like trying to
encourage somebody drugs and you say
this ain't good bro
I've done it nine times yeah you're
crazy all right how fast did you run him
out bastard left it all out there yeah
yeah I do like that you're like ten
minutes the next one which isn't
important to you but is to me cuz I'll
eat it is the lottie's traditional
Barbados hot sauce god bless it my
brother I can't do it
I'm freakish man yeah this and you do
this all the time once a week these
people like you what it's not even like
you is this what does that mean yeah
these guys like you like save you got in
a physical fight or something you want
them guys and just get all [ __ ] up and
just like it's nothing oh yeah yeah you
know saying like black cut you know and
it's just like nothing to cite me the
same [ __ ] no yeah I'm crazy yeah I could
tell Payne 100 hot sauce
this one is brutal look at the cover
yeah this other stuff in the store yeah
but I think you'd have to be a
psychopath to eat anything beyond this
like you see the cover on this just a
kid telling me not to do this well it's
like basically a disclaimer that's not
to show you like why we want it he said
it maybe you're like hey just keep it
honest to each other for the YouTube
news I think that's great make the kids
laugh oh my god when you getting this
one this one's not finished
it's not that's the whole thing
people said to me but nothing I've never
met a wing I can but I can't do him I
throw on a pretzel go out fool - I gotta
take it easy right
the DJ Khaled branded tells a clear
story yeah
we're champions all I do is win but
anyone who's successful will tell you
that they climbed to the top comes with
a fair share of bumps along the way
tell me about a time at DJ Khaled
slavery caught in hell
he'll never in my life it's had to have
happened at least once I'll never never
catch it out you never like missed a
high window never since or nothing and
never that's one thing I'll make sure I
don't and am I saying if you do then
you're not a winner you'll think it's
sometimes you got to take the fall to
win bigger have I experienced roblox
roblox
shields and people trying to stop the
way of course the only difference with
me is I would rip the [ __ ] door off
ripped off his hinges and puts the
hinges in [ __ ] his hands like that
and then I go through a do what I got to
do I never expect nobody to open the
door and let me just go through now in
time after respect they open the door um
saying and that's cool
but down after you open the door you
guys see who's behind the door
cuz that's when they when it becomes a
different type of hate well so with you
for a while what does that mean you
break through the door you break through
the ceiling you rip the door off and one
that's trying to stop you get to rip the
door off take the hinges because you
don't want them to put the door back on
take the hinges that put the hinges but
then if you give them the hinges come
that now the powers and the [ __ ] boys
hands like nah those hinges the ball
frame just call congratulations you
played yourself you got the hinges now I
ripped it off what you think I wasn't
getting through by the way my feelings
good this [ __ ] ain't good for you bro I
know it's probably like okay promise you
I'm not right right now like this is
like I don't know like what's it show
called Punk'd or something cuz this [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] up right Dave's temporary
insanity hot sauce 12 times hotter than
a jalapeno this [ __ ] old you ready
stomach oh look at me I'm a burp I
[ __ ] up I might but they say no this
ain't me acting this is this is some
real [ __ ] look at me poker face I
stopped trying to tell you you you are
you at all impressed by this or you just
like I've been definitely the question
you use it for your advantage of
survival skills
yeah like when's this well this is what
you do is dude you just they do to do it
very disappointed very disappointed
because this crazy number 9 not Dave's
temporary insanity just full-blown
Dave's insanity Hot Sauce 36 times
hotter than a jalapeno I know you've
checked out but if you just want to like
if you want to just I'm not doing that
my mother one day so I'm very smart and
let me tell you something I'm kind of
stupid what I'm trying to tell you is
just certain things I'm gonna be real to
the people that ate all this in your
show yeah I don't even watched it and it
might be some of my friends gunplay okay
he's crazy let me talk about dumb blood
and that's my friend he's crazy I know
you see this is exactly you see him
saying I expect him to eat this and
drink this [ __ ] like that's what you do
he was [ __ ] poker face all the way
through - I'm trying to tell you see am
i doing that certain people who is this
- different - different costs I don't do
this I can't believe you had me do Kenya
I'm really thinking that you invite me
to bring you some chicken and put some
crazy sauce on my chicken all right
this interview is getting contentious
and it might get wild contentious
depending on how you answer this one
talk to me
sorry on suede today you're talking
about dinosaurs at magazines and I was
like first off what does he mean my
talking about second off was he talking
about us actually I got love with
complex so what's the dinosaur the
dinosaur is somebody that's in a time
capsule
right and they don't know what the
[ __ ] going on
obvious a out-of-touch everything and
they play themselves all day what they
should do is put somebody that really
cares about the game and that knows
what's going on beside the dinosaur
because the dinosaur might be the boss
but guess where every real boss is gonna
have an amazing team to make the boss
look good that's why you put them in
power to work but sometimes dinosaurs
want to take full control dinosaurs all
you want to take four well guess what he
played himself last wing and last
question it's tradition here started
[ __ ] with you though but I think that
you started doing all that [ __ ] I'm not
like cuz I got I'm not a superhero I got
a look at all these wings that I've
eaten they've all been crazy [ __ ] crazy
now this particular hot sauce is a pure
chilli extract Mad Dog three fifty seven
seventy one point four times hotter than
a jalapeno I don't even like hot sauce
period on any of my food you don't do
three of them was amazing okay
congratulations
very brave effort Keller all right there
we go I'm [ __ ] up let's say he got to
be miss I'm [ __ ] up gonna be a hard
answer question so the thing about this
I was like tasty affairs like oh they're
so good every artist decided to do this
[ __ ] like people actually come to this
you and Tony Yayo are the only two that
didn't make it all the way through yeah
don't play went through machine can
Kelly went through made quite the
[ __ ] scene but he got all the way
through what do you say to the people
who think DJ college is somebody who
screams to be the best on tracks the
guys that don't know about 25 crates the
guys I just think you're a hype man what
do you say to those people I tell them
to bow down and kneel to their sport
when they see me on their inspiration
I'm who they want to be you're saying
their girl loves me everything they
don't have I had
it's called jealousy ones envy it's
called [ __ ] boy all right well I made it
through so 30-second plug you get 15
seconds but read the script I got to
take 15 seconds to it's no problem
all right man floors yours that camera
or that camera let the people know hey
yo is DJ Cali
my album in stores October 23rd
pre-order right now on iTunes shout out
Spotify another one thank you for
watching season one we're gonna come at
you even harder season two if you're an
artist if you're an actor if you're an
athlete and you think you can go wing
for wing against me come to the hot ones
stage show that you have some nuts and
get into the studio and take on some
questions take on some wings you want my
advice don't play yourself
Oh pjk my look still not used to it
being legal here I feel sketchy yeah
that's like [ __ ] the ringing reminds me
some Christmas [ __ ] like hey people say
blood guys have big dicks is that true
yes death